primero fueron facer y biotech después
la vacuna rusa sputnik 5 y ahora es el
turno de moderna la compañía
estadounidense anunció que su vacuna
experimental contra el hobbit 19 tiene
un 94 5% de efectividad la comunidad
científica lo celebra
y creo que es increíblemente alentador
ver que los resultados de la vacuna
spicer están respaldados por los nuevos
resultados del ensayo de la vacuna
moderna buckingham
la solución está desarrollada con
tecnología conocida como mensajero y
como ventaja no necesita estar a
temperaturas ultra frías a diferencia
del ifycel ivian tech
de estar a punto de ser talado a
patrimonio nacional una hilera en
nairobi kenia conocida entre los locales
como more humo y va a ser eliminada para
construir una carretera sin embargo la
presión de activistas ambientales salvó
la vida del árbol
necesitamos encontrar un equilibrio
entre el desarrollo y nuestros espacios
verdes no podemos sacrificar los por
nada ni siquiera por el progreso
habitantes de la zona aseguran que la
higuera tiene poderes mágicos los
ancianos suelen hacer ofrendas allí para
pedir lluvias en épocas de sequía
sadat rahman adolescente de bangladesh
se hizo con el premio internacional de
la paz infantil 2020 su mérito haber
desarrollados libertines una aplicación
móvil que lucha contra el ciberacoso the
fight against ciber bullying es bike
guard la lucha contra el ciber acoso es
como una guerra y en esta batalla yo soy
un guerrero si todos me siguen apoyando
juntos ganaremos la batalla contra este
problema wild wind this bed insidewing
mediante la aplicación los jóvenes
pueden contactar con voluntarios que
llevarán los incidentes a la policía oa
los trabajadores sociales antes este
premio lo ganaron referentes como malala
o greta samberg
[Música]
de origen humilde afro latino y guy
ritchie torres jamás imaginó ser
congresista de los eeuu sin embargo a
sus 32 años es el primer representante
afro latino abiertamente homosexual es
importante que la gente sienta que mi
candidatura es histórica represento la
posibilidad de que un niño pobre un niño
negro un niño latino o un niño el jefe
te pueda superar cualquier obstáculo y
convertirse en miembro de la legislatura
más poderosa del mundo el congreso de
eeuu
richie de origen puertorriqueño creció
en una vivienda pública con su madre
soltera según ha declarado su lucha
consistirá en garantizar vivienda a todo
el mundo y en conseguir justicia para la
comunidad lgbt
en tierradentro empezamos el guaraní
hace historia el idioma cooficial de
paraguay sonará por primera vez en los
premios latin grammy tierra adentro es
un grupo paraguayo que trata de
reivindicar el folclore tradicional y
fusionarlo con el rock más contemporáneo
un mestizaje musical con el que sueñan
que el mundo descubra el guaraní la
lengua ancestral de paraguay pensamos
[Música]